the woman who's the cutter came with a
razor and
had done something down there but i
wasn't aware what
wasn't really particularly aware of what
she did i remember the pain so
distinctly we weren't sedated
the pain was excruciating it was
excruciating as you remember crying i do
remember screaming
i didn't pass out
i was born in chichester
and i come from a sudanese background
interesting dynamics living as a
sudanese family in in the uk didn't
really have a lot of
sydney's people around me not that much
of a big community but very very in
touch with australia's culture so spoke
arabic at home and would occasionally
visit growing up uh sit down to go see
my family
none of my family apart from my mum my
dad and my brother
i actually live in england i remember
my parents saying that we're gonna go to
qatar that my whole family was going to
be there
in my mind it was just a family trip
where we were seeing cousins aunties
uncles
but
i don't know how long it was into
the holiday when
we were doing all of the quite unquote
like circumcisions
in any culture i feel like boys tend to
get treated a little bit more
differently i would say that girls can
sometimes be upheld to
to fulfill
you know a certain role like trying to
like retain
purity and it's a right of passage into
womanhood that is done to suppress
sexuality
i do remember
everyone having it done on the same day
so it was myself my brother
and
another cousin of mine who is a girl
and
two or three other boy cousins as well
and we all just kind of like
went in there separately like
sort of like getting called in
to
a doctor's surgery and i just remember
seeing this woman who i do recall
calling her a witch like she did
frighten me
and then you get
held
down and
the woman who's the cutter came with a
razor and
had done something down there but i
wasn't aware what
wasn't really particularly aware of what
she did
i remember the pain so distinctly we
weren't sedated there weren't any
painkillers it was just
a woman with a razor and getting held
down by by by family members i do
remember feeling super super scared in
that moment and i remember the after
pain as well just being really brutal
but i do remember being on antibiotics
afterwards just to prevent any
infections
it's so crazy because everything that
happened after
being
cursed and being held out i don't
remember i'm not quite sure why i don't
remember and i don't know whether it's
me just trying to suppress after that
we celebrated
basically the
coming of age or like
our right of passage into womanhood and
they took pictures of us with henna and
like beautiful incense that you could
just smell in the room
but then upon coming back i really had
no idea what
had happened and it wasn't something i
spoke about because it was not made to
be a big deal because it was just so
entrenched in the cultural norms of what
a woman is to go through at that age
so there are four types of fgm um type
one
is where the [ __ ] gets removed that's
what the world war health organization
would claw
we'll call a clitorodectomy
um and then type two
is where they will partially or totally
remove the [ __ ] and partially or totally
remove the labia
and then type three is
the partial the total removal of the
[ __ ] the partial the total removal of
the labia and surrounding areas as well
and then type four is when they do
all of the above
um and then tend to sew it up and leave
just a tiny hole
and the one that happened to me was type
one where they partially
um
removed
the [ __ ]
i
was 17 when i found out what happened
was fgm i sat with my
two friends at the time and my brother
and we were generally just speaking
about circumcision i don't know that's a
normal thing to do my brother had just
mentioned oh yes sarah's been
circumcised and then my friend sort of
looks at me like
women don't get circumcised so at that
point i'm still thinking that that's a
normal thing that everyone goes through
and i think i was super just
embarrassed
and angry at my brother for mentioning
it
i remember coming home and having a few
conversations with my mum like
you know
what the hell actually happened when i
was four or five and it was that penny
drop moment where i was just googling
and i started getting really scared
because i don't actually know what
happened to me down there i've never
really looked down there i haven't seen
what
what got taken from me i don't know what
they circumcised and i do remember just
being super super ashamed of the fact
that i
had
female circumcision attached to my name
amongst my friends you can be
re-traumatized through certain questions
that you might be asked by people and i
understand that there is no malice
intended by certain questions
so like when people might ask you know
like you know what does it look like and
it's like these are questions that can
hinder someone's healing journey
and then the number of conversations
that i had to have afterwards with my
family members about why it happened
and it was really just a case where it
was like it's just the thing that
happened you know my
mum would say oh it happened to me and
then she would say but my gran it
happened to your grandmother as well so
it was just something that just occurred
i recall
us really
getting quite emotional about it because
i'm not the only one that's been through
it but i'm
one of a long line of women in my family
who have been through it um
[Music]
i know that amongst the women in my
family there is this
collective
shared
guilt and i think a lot of blame at the
start because i'm like you know why
would you do that to me but back then i
didn't have the perspective that it was
something that had also occurred to my
mum and also occurred to my aunties and
my grandmothers
i would say that it's
an abusive act but i wouldn't say that i
would like to think that i'm a victim
i'd like to say that i'm more of a
survivor
of someone who
was subjected to that alongside every
single woman in my family that was
subjected to it as well
i don't think it was until i became
19 or 20
that i felt more comfortable about
speaking out about my experiences
because then i had
a vision that this was something that
i want to put an end to and it did end
with my cohort of cousins
i know that
there's definitely remorse but i think
it's also important to note that it's a
collective trauma
so i don't feel like i was owed
an apology it's
not our family or anyone's family that's
the issue
it's the
the culture that it's entrenched in
that's the issue
me being born here meant that i had
and have a lot of privilege when it
comes to navigating certain spaces and
speaking about things like this i was
the only one who was actually speaking
out about it and wanting to put an end
to that generational trauma that we were
all carrying but no one was talking
about and it became just this
collective thing that everyone in my
family wanted to do as well so we all
empowered each other through our
experiences and made an active effort to
actually open up the dialogue and remove
the stigma and the shame that's attached
to speaking out about it
when that
law had been passed that fgm is now
criminalized in sedan it was like okay
this is a step forward
i'm super super proud of how far my
family's come we've been able to
collectively come together as women and
just empower each other in our
experiences and i feel like that's
something that is a true blessing in my
family i know that there is an air of
shame when it comes to speaking out
about fgm in certain communities and
certain families
i just want to show women that there's a
lot more of us out there that have been
through it and that if you feel like a
space is safe enough to discuss these
things
then do it
[Music]
today i'm going to be talking about how
i grew up in a cult there was no tv in
our house we weren't allowed to watch
movies or television shows we weren't
allowed to listen to any
contemporary non-christian music i was
not allowed to cut my hair i was not
allowed to wear makeup i was not allowed
to wear high heels i felt like there
were so many rules